شتاء قاتم في الخارج كما كان صيفًا وربيعًا في طهران
قبل أن
يكون التخفيف نادرًا ، مات أكثر من 750 شخصًا من
فيروس كورونا في هذه الممرات ،
وهناك امرأة شابة أخرى عندما وصلنا
للتو انعطافًا إلى الزاوية يمثل
بداية وحدة العناية المركزة
هنا ميتان هو يوم جيد للمعدل  ويقول
تسعة
أطباء سيئين إن
بطولة إيران والوباء كانت
أكثر شراسة
لأنهم يفعلون ذلك تحت
الضغط الأقصى لعقوبات الإدارة الرابحة
إنهم فخورون بما فعلوه
بهذه المعدات بقدر ما هم غاضبون
أن كل ما لديهم هو واحد من
أكثر البلدان تضررًا
في الشرق الأوسط من فيروس كورونا
الذي يعانون منه ، ويقولون إنه
أكثر حدة بسبب
تأثير العقوبات التي فرضتها الولايات المتحدة على
الخليف ، لا يبدو الأمر كذلك ولكنه أفضل بكثير.
ذهبت ذات يوم إلى اليوم أه في نزهة في
الخارج
أه في إحدى الحدائق وهي
حيث أعتقد أننا
أصيبنا بفيروس كورونا أكثر من ذي قبل
ألم شديد في صدري
عقوبة انقباض
قاسية على أمريكا
القاسية  نعم
، توفي 300 موظف طبي في إيران بسبب
هذه الوظيفة ،
لكن مثل جميع الأرقام هنا ، فهي
تحت رحمة
معدات الاختبار المحدودة والإرهاق ،
ولكن حتى في تلك الفوضى العددية ،
توفي 10000 رسميًا في نوفمبر وحده
من 19 سرية
ويبدو أن  هنا لنصبح أصغر سناً ،
قيل لنا
إن أكثر الأيام مرارة كان عندما كان لدي 47
عامًا وأم لثلاثة أطفال هنا
، يقول إنها لم تستجب للعلاج
عندما ماتت ،
وكان ذلك أفظع يوم
بالنسبة لي لم أستطع حفظه
إنها عالقة في ذاكرتي
، وإذا كنت قد خسرت القتال ، فغالبًا ما
تتجه جنوبًا
عبر المدينة إلى حيث توجد
مساحة صغيرة أو كثيرة
في اقتصاد المقبرة
(الموسيقى)
وقياس كل منزل أخير بدقة حتى عند
وصول الجثث
[موسيقى]
صلاة الإمام هنا عالقة في حلقة
من الضياع
[موسيقى]
يتردد صداها على مدار
اليوم في كل يوم من عشرات الأئمة الذين
يقودون حوالي 30 جنازة في اليوم
، وعادة ما تجمد شاشة المرأة
كل شخص لها
كادت أن تخسر
لا أحد يريد التحدث ، لكن القصص
خارج الكاميرا كانت مشابهة
لمرض السكري في أواخر الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ،
فإن نقاط الضعف التي تدعم
الذكريات العزيزة
للمغادرين وتغذي كل طقوس
رعاية أخيرة تدور حول هذه المقابر وليست
ثقوبًا وحتى عملية قاتمة  الاضمحلال
يتعامل بدقة
مع العالم الخارجي قد لا يرى
الصورة الكاملة لمعركة إيران
مع نفس العدو الذي واجهناه جميعًا أو
نقدر مقدار الشلل
الذي جعله تشديد العقوبات المتعمد يجعله
نيك بايتون والش سي إن طهران